right now we're in a place of anger and
anger has to come out think of it like
having um
a fight with someone you love your
spouse your boyfriend your girlfriend
a friend right um where you have a
relationship
it's a sibling right you have a
relationship where there's no getting
out of this relationship
um and um and and because there has been
very bad communication for so long that
all of the slights and all of the little
things that
that noodled and needed us in these
relationships
it happens at work sometimes too we
constantly somebody's always cutting us
off in a meeting somebody's constantly
interrupting us
and eventually one day we just start we
just lose it we slam our hand on the
desk and say
will you just stop interrupting me and
there's a fight
and there's anger and then all it takes
is one person
either party to listen
and try to understand where the anger is
coming from
and then there's a dialogue and then
both parties start listening
and then you usually end up hugging and
being grateful and though you don't want
to go through that experience again you
were grateful that it happened
because it forced each
party to listen and try to understand
the position of the other
and those friendships friendships and
marriages that have
have been able to navigate stress
together
and learn to listen and hear each other
are way stronger as a result
our society is going through the same
thing we have to allow for the letting
of the anger
you can't when somebody slams their f
their fist on the table
the worst thing we can do is say that's
not going to help
there's there's a process to this and
and
what it takes now is for people to to
start to try and understand
and either party it can come from either
side it can come from law enforcement it
can come from
uh the african-american community come
from the general community come from
people who've been wrong people have it
doesn't matter it can come from anywhere
where somebody says i need to understand
what you go through because we will not
find a solution until we find common
[Music]
understanding
you